before we go we want to tell you about a  Minnesota family who are crediting the  country rap hit old town road for giving  their autistic son a verbal breakthrough  [Music]  that's four year old Daniel Brundage he  had only spoken about three words in his  entire life  until last week that's when he went up  to his mother singing old town road she  recorded that unexpected moment and  shared it on Twitter Daniels therapists  are now focusing on using music in his  sessions really words in his entire life  and you imagine mom what she was  thinking you know he never speaks he's  and he's singing that pretty good too  you know exactly what he was saying